so let's review of how we got to where
we are right now in 1789 you have the
revolution in france
this makes the french very proud a lot
of nationalistic pride it also makes the
rest of europe a little worried they're
they're all monarchies they don't like
this idea of overthrowing your kings and
so during this revolutionary period you
have a series of wars with the rest of
europe revolutionary france does
essentially the french revolutionary
wars and during that period napoleon
becomes quite famous as the french and
maybe the best european military
commander so now
napoleon is starting to become
essentially a hero in france and by 1799
he's able to come to power in a coup
d'etat with a couple of other people and
then he out maneuvers them and then by
1804 he becomes the emperor napoleon and
he's and this whole period he is now
starting to expand the empire so these
were the revolutionary wars now these
you can consider right over here the
napoleonic wars and the peak of the
french empire under napoleon happens in
1812 and the real downfall if if you ask
my opinion and many other people it
would be when he invaded russia that
really decimated the french grand army
and then we saw in the last video by
april of 1814 he by this the sixth
coalition was finally successful against
napoleon and then he was
he was exiled to the island
the island of elba which is now where
we're we're taking up the story
he only hung out there for about a
little under 10 months he started one he
was separated from his family so the
even though he might have you know been
put in charge of this little island it
was not maybe what he wanted and he
obviously was a very ambitious person on
top of that he caught wind of what was
going on in in france louis the 18th was
there the nobility returned they weren't
treating the old army veterans well
which made him suspect that he might be
able to maybe retake control somehow
on top of that the french empire was
being shrunken back to its original
boundaries which made many people in
france a lot less proud so napoleon
started to sense that maybe he could do
something on top of that he caught wind
that people might not leave him in elba
because he is napoleon and they were
afraid that he might come back so they
might banish him to some place even more
remote
or there might be some attempts to
assassinate him so with that in mind
being who he is and being as creative as
he is he's able to somehow escape from
alba he's able to get a boat
land on the southern shores of france
the french authorities are able to catch
wind of this they send the military to
engage with him so this is a french
military to essentially confront capture
kill napoleon on the on the southern
shores of france and when he sees them
he dismounts from the horse that he's
got he walks up to them completely
unarmed and says go ahead
shoot your emperor
which was in my mind a fairly gutsy move
to do
and they rally around him and he's able
to actually take control of the army
that was sent to capture or kill him and
he starts marching to paris
he starts marching to paris louis the
18th the brave man that he is catches
wind of this and escapes
and so you have
by march of 1815 napoleon is able to
retake control of paris and essentially
france and this is the beginning of what
is known as the hundred days
the
100 days and it actually is about 111
days but that just doesn't sound as good
so it's 111 days between march of 1815
and july of 1815. well you can imagine
even before napoleon was able to reach
paris a few days before he was able to
reach paris word got around to the rest
of europe what's going on that napoleon
was back they didn't like it they
essentially announced that they would
not stand by there and they were going
to start forming a new coalition to stop
him so napoleon had two options once he
gets to paris he could essentially
option one was essentially sit and wait
wait for the combined forces of europe
to kind of
reorganize and then attack him or he
could go he could go on the offensive he
could attack before they had a chance to
fully regroup
so you can imagine he viewed this as
being his best shot so he starts going
after the combined forces of great
britain and
prussia in what is now belgium and over
there is where he engaged in probably
one of the most there were several
battles but the decisive battle was the
battle of waterloo waterloo which is
possibly one of the most famous battles
in all of history maybe maybe due to
also the the abba song about it and it
was there that he met the duke of
wellington on the british side and and
and bleuker on the prussian side and at
waterloo napoleon had 70 or 80 000
troops the other side had 120 130 000
troops extremely extremely bloody battle
40 50 000 people killed injured missing
on and on and on but in the end napoleon
lost and many historians there's
different reasons for why he lost he
actually did a pretty good job
considering the scenario the ground
because of the weather weather was very
muddy and actually was not good for
being on the offense it was very good
conditions for being on the defense as
we know napoleon was essentially trying
to
take out
these somewhat remnant armies before the
the the coalition the the seventh
coalition essentially had had a chance
to fully to fully uh get back to full
force but he loses at waterloo there are
a few skirmishes after that but the
french retreat back to paris and at this
point napoleon sees the writing on the
wall he's not completely delusional he
sees that if they were able to
especially if the prussians are able to
get him again they might not let him
live they might really do something
crazy with him so he surrenders himself
to the british and then
they exiled him to the island of saint
helena which is one of the very remote
islands that he was afraid of to being
exiled to to begin with and just to give
a sense of how remote it is
this right over here is the south west
coast of africa so this is africa right
over here saint helena is right out over
here almost in the middle of the
atlantic between africa and south
america and that's where napoleon would
live out the rest of his life in a very
uncomfortable situation much worse than
what he had going on in elba separated
from everyone else
and then he dies in 1821 the official
cause and this is what many historians
do believe actually happened is that
that he died of stomach cancer
but many there are theories that it
might there might have been some type of
assassination some slow arsenic
poisoning there was a lot of arsenic
in in his tissue uh his body was
unusually well preserved after his death
that's one of the things that arsenic
does some people think it might have
been our inadvertent arsenic poisoning
because of the environment that he was
in the conditions even it might have
been um the paint in in in the walls but
either way he really lived out roughly
the last the last six or seven last six
years
in a pretty unpleasant conditions and
and then died of stomach cancer and that
was essentially the final end of
napoleon